i love kids so much my mom was a
high school teacher so my whole life i
grew up in a school let's go on to our
next point we're looking
for more technology i love having energy
in the classroom and just being lively
and
a light for the kids is maths today
these maps didn't just get created
overnight right
martial arts and training in general has
changed so much for me it's built me up
in my confidence and
just in like you said in my dreams and
my hopes um
it's shown me incredible strength that i
didn't even know i had
and just opened up a world of
opportunity it's definitely taught me
just to
work at something with all your might
and that you have to prioritize for sure
it's a long day every day because i
train every day and i'm here every day
but it's worth it and so it definitely
teaches me
just perseverance trying to help them to
navigate their
way my biggest hope is to love on my
kids and to inspire them
whether it's in the classroom or in what
i do in fighting like i just love for
them to see
um that you can be strong and you can
follow your dreams and
be a light in the process of it some of
the
economical and political systems or the
government
began to understand trade more
emotionally
they are both so hard because there's
all the build up in fighting
but in teaching there's 27 little kids
that i'm trying to like
live on and feed into and grow um
and so that's challenging too but
honestly
i think teaching i think teaching
fighting is hard don't get me wrong
and it shows you that you're stronger
than you think but this job
is hard